monica good morning to you hi monica hey
guys thank you so much hope you guys had
a great weekend you have fun this
weekend oh yeah it was busy out there
i know i did it was awesome and i i was
so
pumped up about this next interview
because i just love this guy
las vegas guys is the entertainment
capital of the world you know that but
everything came to a screeching halt
during the pandemic y'all know how it
happened
finally though our city is coming back
and joining me live
is this man i like to call family i just
love him i gush over him all the time
so i'll just apologize now this is chuck
bowling he is the president and ceo
of mandalay bay delano and the luxor
yeah he's the king of the strip
i'll get in trouble for that but anyway
good morning chuck how are you good
morning great monica how are you doing
today
i am doing so good hey listen you know i
want to paint the picture chuck
of what happened last year because we
were thriving things were going well
and i remember the day because delano
had reached out to you things were
starting to happen and we heard that
okay the strip is about to shut down
and the moment he reached out to you you
responded back to him and said i just
locked the doors
of mandalay bay and we were shaken i
can't imagine how you were feeling
what was that day like well it's it's
something i'll never forget i mean we
were
in a meeting just 30 days earlier
talking about what was could potentially
be the best year in mandalay bay's
history
and then we had a chance to gather our
employees and
on top of this pandemic and say i'll
tell you what we're going to close these
doors on march 12th and i'll see you in
april
uh i just didn't know it was april 21. i
missed it by that much
but i will paint a picture for you
that's hard to believe where we were and
how far we've come about a year ago
i finished putting up our last piece of
plywood on all the doors to make sure
the building's safe
one year ago i was standing in the
middle of mandalay bay with all the
lights off
with myself and a handful of employees
and that's when reality really set in
and it was a very very scary time uh
as far as where we were and quite
frankly we didn't know where we were
going and so
i remember it like it was yesterday but
we always talk about
las vegas and mandalay bay and and uh
about being this great exciting energy
town but it's a town of perseverance we
went into mode of
how are we going to take care of our
employees yeah uh you know we uh started
how we're going to communicate to them
we started through the mgm resorts
foundation
raising millions of dollars to make sure
that our team was going to have the
ability
to survive this mess no idea how long it
was going to take
yeah and chuck you know what i know this
for a fact and ladies and gentlemen i
think you all know me well enough
to know i i don't fake the funk this man
i have watched him walk the floor of
mandalay bay
speak to his people he addresses a lot
of them by name he walks
he touches and connects with his people
i've not seen that done with a lot of
people
in his position so i just want to put
that out there chuck bowling really
cares
about his folks so chuck as you were you
were going through that process
and you were thinking i know you have to
pull yourself together because you got
to be the leader
mind body spirit emotions how are you
right now as you guys
ramp up to reopen get everybody back to
work
well that's an exciting time and and i
don't know who's leading who when you
watch
an employee who's been off for a year
walk through that front door and the
energy and excitement
that you see in their eyes and the
balance in the step
it motivates me because it's been a long
year it's been a long year about
protecting our buildings protecting our
employees communicating with our
employees but now that we're coming back
and it's been an exciting day all the
way from june of last year
uh to the incredible ramp up we've seen
over the last eight weeks we are seeing
numbers that we haven't seen
since 2019 and some numbers quite
frankly are better than 2019
so it's an exciting time and we want to
do it first and foremost with health and
safety in mind
and of course the key to that is
everybody getting vaccinated it is
absolutely critical
that people coming to las vegas know
that we've got a safe
and healthy environment uh so that they
feel comfortable coming here and letting
their hair down and have fun so
again i'm happy to leave the employees
but quite fully and the employees are
leading me
because of the energy and excitement and
i'm just trying to uh hang on
where you are hanging on well my friend
okay so if everybody is
watching this right now they're like i
don't know if i'm ready to come to las
vegas
entice them to come to las vegas tell
them what they're in store for at the
mandalay bay in luxor
well you're going to see a lot of energy
and excitement the greatest restaurants
in the world
are now open some of the greatest
entertainment is starting to come back
at carrot top and fantasy we announced a
blue man group and cirque is coming
back this summer uh i know all of us are
dying for live
live entertainment we can't wait for it
to come back but more importantly the
the entertainers can't wait to get back
on the stages so if you missed a concert
over the last four or five years
you're in store for the fact that you're
probably going to see him come on tour
and you're going to see him come through
las vegas the pools are coming back
the one thing that i will say is that we
need our convention business to come
back and i'm here to report that the
convention business is starting to come
back in june
the second half of the year looks great
for mandalay based convention center but
las vegas convention center and the
whole part of that
and that's kind of some of the final
pieces that we're excited to see back
which brings more employees back to uh
to manly bay and luxembourg
all right chuck now you know i'm gonna
press you for this i know you got a lot
of secrets
you care to share eddie with us any
surprises coming up that you want to
break
right here on mondays with monica on
eight news now
well i'm gonna tell you we got uh good
news coming almost every
week coming up for the next several
months are going to be something new
that's going to be opening and we
certainly have a
what we believe is going to be exciting
announcement in early summer about
something coming to luxor that we will
uh we will announce shortly but
every week is something coming up of
course one thing that we know about the
entertainment capital were a great
production shows great entertainment
shows but things we were missing
was things surrounded about a stadium
tour coming up and by the way there's
this little thing right next to mandalay
bay and luxon called the allegiant
stadium
that we're ready to activate and get
going and i think garth brooks is going
to kick that off on july 10th and then
the rest is history
all right my friend hey i'm out of time
but i want to say finally thank you you
know we announced that the moj show is
coming to
the mandalay bay delano and like
everything and everybody else we were
completely shut down as a result
of the pandemic but i want to say thank
you for staying in touch with us
me and my team especially my husband
delano thank you for
inviting us and we are still coming so
is the door still open
come on come on down one and all we're
excited to welcome everybody back to
family bay delano luxor and quite
frankly all of las vegas high tides
lifts all boats so we're excited about
what's happening in las vegas
all right chuck bowling thank you so
much we so appreciate it and good luck
to you
and the peeps over at mandalay bay the
entire las vegas trip with mandalay bay
and luxor
you got it going on my friend we
appreciate to take care
thank you monica all right okay and
don't forget folks to catch my mlj show
facebook
live tonight at 7 00 p.m yeah you know
we're going to be talking about this
again so you can watch
the replay with mr chuck bolling and
sherry
i know you know chuck as well we
actually were talking about him
um there was an ev i can't remember what
event we were at but we were sitting at
the same table
everybody gushes over chuck yeah and in
our little circle
everybody says you know everybody loves
chuck that's the same
but not like he's not like other ceos
you know he's a cool guy he's a very
cool guy well you could hear his email
going off ding ding
people watching him on tv this morning
hey chuck cool you got your own show
have a good day las vegas yeah and his
wife claire supports him love you claire
good job all right nice to have some
inside information there